oh yeah I read something that interested
me and its current more the the the
folklore of Nick Nolte the de mugshot of
you the kind of has sure your hair is
all wild and everything that was not
actually a mug shot nosa nosa isn't that
crazy I didn't know that yeah no in fact
that was released in England before was
released in the united states because
that was their anniversary in 911 so all
the challenge were pointed to New York
and to where the terrorists were going
to bomb again and the only thing that
happened on there that days I got pulled
over for driving under the influence and
the guy was very power jet he said he
drove me down the hospital I wouldn't
let them you know I did the breath thing
there was nothing but I wouldn't handle
the entertainment hospital do blood
tests I didn't think they had the test
you know it was that Noah Bethea and he
said gee I'm really sorry mr. novian you
know boy hey man I was on the wrong side
of the street street on PCH sound asleep
running people off the road I'm glad you
saw me sure I was totally irresponsible
and I saw the camera down there and we
got out of the car he said he didn't
mind if I get a shot against the wall
and if you look at the wall you can see
that it's two toned yes I said yeah yeah
yeah yes to talk that's not a mud
background so he just asked to take a
photo of you ain't a photo and I said to
look if you'll share the money then I'll
do it he said share what money either
come on but yeah you know don't don't
take the first bit you know they'll
probably start around 20 25 thousand you
can get it up to forty fifty thousand
dollars but share with the other
sheriff's and I don't know if he did it
or not they don't wow you don't talk
about it
they don't like me talking look but
that's the story that's the story my the
real issue though is that is the the
shirt choice that's one of the best
things in the world is McNulty's fashion
choices when he's just on his own left
his own accord like the new one thats
everywhere is you walking around in a
poncho yeah you know and it's like it's
like it looks like the most comfortable
guy in the world yeah but certainly not
fashion choices where he's like oh I'm
really worried what people are gonna
think of me today that's the beauty of
nuh that's what's gonna say on your on
your gravestone Nick Nolte he didn't
give a [ __ ] yeah buddy left the house
it's awesome